yo I wanted to talk to you because you
know there's this culture in La where
there's artists who will come out here
they'll have big homies out here but
they're not from here right yeah and um
you'll see like a situation like a
um
I'm sure you saw what happened with
quando Rondo yeah quote-unquote dropped
the flag pretty much yeah said he's
because because I think he was was he
banging wrong 60s I think so yeah I
think he was from 60s yeah um his friend
died obviously he was going through it
you know yeah um but you know I know
that that's
I mean certain people will look at that
and be like good for him other people
will be like what the [ __ ] you know like
just
the thing right like no matter how far I
go no matter where I go no matter what I
do I give a [ __ ] if I just got a song
with Lady Gaga if she's still relevant
yeah of course she's Lady Gaga She'll
always yeah yeah I know so if I had a
song with Lady Gaga and I blew up and I
had the most money in the world
or not even that that tube or if I'm in
a car and three of my homies get smoked
right in front of me right I'm a [ __ ]
until I go to until I'm done it's just
it's just that's it's not it's like a
fraternity like you if you're in [ __ ]
college and you're from Alpha Phi Alpha
even when you graduate and you get your
job at the end of it my [ __ ] is 78
years old or 80 years old you're still
gonna have your colors you're still
gonna have your logo you're still going
to pull up to those meetings so [ __ ]
any [ __ ] that stop banging
I really don't condone it you know like
actively like actively being in the
street and gang banging and fighting and
killing and [ __ ] like okay [ __ ] stop
that right right grow and evolve and
metamorphosize but to just drop your
flag no yeah yeah you can't drop your
flag yeah cause I feel like like you
were saying like you want to grow you
don't want to always be in the streets
but that doesn't mean that you're gonna
disown where you come from at the same
time exactly exactly that's fair you
know what I'm saying